.
>> Tucker: GREAT POINT.
DR. MARK SEAGULL, GREAT TO ZOO
YOU TONIGHT.
THE FBI HAS HAD HUNTER BIDEN'S
LAP TOP FOR MORE THAN THREE
YEARS.
ON THAT IS INFORMATION ABOUT
CRIMES.
HUNTER BIDEN HAS NOT BEEN
CHARGED BY FEDERAL AUTHORITIES
OR RAIDED EITHER.
HE DIDN'T PRAY AT AN ABORTION
CLINIC.
BASICALLY EVERYONE INVESTIGATING
THE CONTENTS OF THE LAP TOP ARE
UNDER INVESTIGATION BY THE DOJ.
WE LOOK INTO THE BIDEN'S EFFORTS
TO CRUSH THIS STORY.
HERE IS PART OF IT.
>> Tucker: NEARLY EVERYONE
INVOLVED IN INVESTIGATING
HUNTER'S BUSINESS PRACTICES HAVE
BEEN INVESTED, INDICTED OR
RAIDED.
RUDY GUILIANI HAD HIS HOME
SEARCHED AND COMPUTER SEIZED BY
THE FBI.
THE FBI EXECUTED A SEARCH
WARRANT AT THE HOME OF VICTORIA
WHO WORKED WITH AOU RAINIANS TO
UNCOVER MORE INFORMATION.
OTHERS WHO HELPED RUDY GUILIANI
INVESTIGATE HUNTER BIDEN WERE
ARRESTED ON CAMPAIGN FINANCE
CHARGES.
>> Tucker: ONCE AG